thank you thank you Stephane invited me
as an economist but he probably he
doesn't know that I'm i repented economy
so economy so I hope that you want to
repent to have invited me here I just I
just begin with with what seemed pretty
simple observation that that came out
this morning to my mind listening it
most of the thing I i looked at I didn't
know really the distraction the
importance of what is happening in this
moment in the world so it is obvious
that the heritage is a very relevant
political target is a very relevant
political issue at the same time if I
really figure out what is happening for
example in my country the kind of
awareness to the people this my students
do have about what is happening is
completely low is very low so at the
same time heritage is a very strong
political relevant issue and on the
other side is a completely unreal event
issue and we need to know that we are
shifting among these two sides of the
story so what is happening with the
editors is a little bit like what is
happening with our bodies I was working
with it let's say not work in talking
with a dancer and he said to me right
walk do the same thing but slowing down
ninety percent and I begin to understand
that I was not able to walk ninety
percent most lowly because I didn't know
if my hands were going up before the
knee and how I put my foot so I habit my
body without being aware of my body and
this is a little bit what happening with
the area that we inhabit the air it but
we are not aware and this is the
political agenda of Europe we need to
admit our failure in lighting the people
having this kind of awareness so having
this kind of misunderstanding in mind I
I I think that probably ah now this is
not my presentation I'm sorry I changed
it this morning anyway I can do it I can
do it without
I can do that the point the point is who
me that we need to know that way to
figure out than the problem of managing
the coaster the conservation of heritage
is as its double-sided we need to
maintain the era tidge and to maintain
the awareness of the note of the
meanings of the heritage but not only in
the technical environment in the in the
people in the local communities we need
to cope with this process and to
maintain this process is a very complex
task because we need to talk with a
multiple stakeholders environment and we
need to understand the need to produce
different chain of values at the same
time so this is an interpreter riyal
task and a very difficult task so it's a
very sophisticated operation that we
normally don't trying we don't join the
people to this task we train the people
to be very good in maintaining the
object and understanding the value we
train the people to be good manager of
anything we don't train the people to
know how to cope with this complexity so
now now this is the basic so then I
produce a kind of theoretical frame and
then be lost in the in the in the maybe
i can i can give the theoretical thing
tomorrow if i will have the opportunity
to talk again if you let me stay fer but
but um what i will tell you after this
is why i repented as an economist
because I've been in bham I went in bham
in 2004 and yeah maybe
this is I would like to have
representation
can I can I keep this moment adding this
moment of my presentations at the time
like in the rugby match okay
okay I've been in bun and and we did we
did a study on on on bomb in order to
understand if the people it was april
two thousand four it was four months as
after the earthquake the earthquake
killed eight thousand people if i
remember it was a catastrophic event and
the people were living in tents with no
gutter no water in desperate condition
and there was his intention to
understand if they really wanted the
reconstruction of the Citadel if they
wanted the complete reconstruction of
the partial reconstruction if it was a
priority against other priorities and
and so we went around doing interview
with the political bodies but also we
have a kind of a questionnaire that have
been distributed by the student of care
man it was very difficult to get those
information so i just want to tell you
some of the evidence that came out
sixty-three percent was a sample think
that the reconstruction of the arc is an
immediate priority even if they don't
have water and don't have houses and
don't have hospitals and don't have
schools for their children and they are
starving and and forty percent wants the
total reconstruction oh then the numbers
was very small so we cannot say that
this is a representative sample it was a
kind of scratching the surface above the
of the entire body of the population but
then the metaphoric expression most are
used often describe the ark as a part of
the physical body the major of the bomb
that lost his wife and children in the
quake says it was our pride and
distinction i used to walk there since I
was a child was part of myself like my
hand BAM without the ark is like a man
who cannot breathe we can say that art
is the father and the houses are the Sun
so we the metaphor more often physical
metaphor of loss right and if we looked
at the distribution of of the
preferences it was tracked me at that
time is
the people that were asking for an
immediate priority independently from
the Adamic so you have immediate
priority here and one hundred percent
damages immediate priority even if you
have lower level of damages are the
people that were living nearby the
seated while while you go into the
peripheral part of the town the
preferences were in a sense more
differentiated like the physical
presence who are hitting their body and
producing a preference that was
apparently non-rational because they
didn't have homes they didn't have water
than half gutter they didn't have
anything so what we concluded from this
the idea that you had this kind of
feeling that was an enormous resources
for the reconstruction of the city
though but in fact the impression that
we had is that the decision about about
the the reconstruction of the sea todo
didn't cope with that availability in
fact the community wasn't involved as
far as I understood into the
reconstruction of the Citadel so what I
can say after this first thing I
understood that that the situation and
the Heritage produces condition that
challenge what economists suggest us to
know so rationality and Muslim and
Marlowe scale of references so people
react to the heritage damage in way
there are surprising and the second
point is that we need to take this
possibility or this say availability
into the management plan of our sites
into the way in which we are take care
of the communication and this is the
maintenance of the meaning production
and the capability building into the
community which is a crucial activity
in a very entrepreneurial activity and
we need to train and to create the
condition and to and to have be very
focused into this target if we want this
to happen and what is happening now in
Italy what is happening in Europe we are
failing this target thank you